nombre de votants 348
bulletin blanc 22 bulletin nul 6
suffrages exprimé 320 majorité absolue
ont obtenu ce Gérard Larcher
218 voies
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas un votre pas un vote par
acclamation donc je vais vous donner
quand même les scores des autres
candidats ce Patrick canner a obtenu 64
voix
[Applaudissements]
même Cécile Cu Kerman va voir
et monsieur Guillaume Gontard 18 voies
[Applaudissements]
donc Monsieur Gérard Larcher a obtenu la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
au premier tour de scrutin je le
proclame élu président du Sénat et
conformément à l'article premier du
règlement je l'invite à prendre place
aux fauteuil de la présidente que je lui
souhaite bien volontiers et je remercie
le secrétaire d'âge pour leur
participation aux opérations de vote
[Musique]